Okay let's see out memory ordering quiz solution,
this load is still sent to memory in
cycle 1, and will come back in cycle
41. The store, however, cannot proceed fully because we
don't know what the value is until cycle 42 ,So in cycle 42, this store finally
figures out what the address and the value
are, so now this load can be considered done.
Because we need to do things in order, that means that only cycle 43,
this load can start going to memory, It's going to take 40 cycles to come
back, so in cycle 83 the value comes back from memory; at that point.
This store can finish at cycle 84, inside cycle 85
that means that only then this load can go to memory,
It's going to be cycle 125 by the time, it
come back and finally the final store can be
done in cycle 126. As you can see, it
took almost three times as long in this case
to do this as it did when we were trying to do things out of order. So there
is a huge advantage in trying to reorder load
store instructions, but it caries a risk of having
to recover from basically loading the wrong value from memory
because we should have loaded the value from the store.